[Musik]
samuel und virginie sind zwillinge er
hat das down-syndrom sie nicht
[Musik]
samuel wohnt bei virgin ii und ihrer
familie in drei monaten erwartet sie ihr
zweites kind
wie organisieren sich die ungleichen
zwillinge im alltag wie gelingt der
spagat zwischen mutter und schwester
sein
können die bedürfnisse aller auch in
zukunft gestellt werden
patient und der rat auf mithilfe und
verantwortung und aufgabe und dem des
dreifachen nutzen desto besser gott
ich begleite die beiden von jetzt drei
monate vor der geburt bis drei monate
danach
[Musik]
das ist das zuhause von versini ihrem
mann und dem kleinen marvin seit zwei
jahren auch von samuel in unregelmäßigen
abständen wohnt er zudem bei den eltern
der chemie arbeitet drei tage pro woche
als lehrerin daneben dem einjährigen
marvin gerecht zu werden samuel und auch
noch sich selbst das stelle ich mir
schwierig vor
ich glaube sich sicher herzen sich die
nägel dreifach für mich das absolute
absolute nummer eins gewählt das er
per schlüsse welche dank klar gibt es im
moment aber es ist weder grundhaltung
dass er integriert ist im islam im
alltag
unterstützt wird die 32 jährige von
ihrem mann
verarbeitet 100 prozent aus
landschaftsgärtner
[Musik]
bis vor zwei jahren lebte samuel in
verschiedenen betreuten institutionen es
sei unglücklich und aggressiv gewesen
bekam medikamente zu beruhigen am
wochenende war er jeweils bei wm oder
den eltern es ist jedes mal
dass sie mir meine stunde lang gewartet
und er im auto mehr gestellt werden
werden uns tun hat wenn wir dann mit
hide fahrer sind hierbei die mäßig
gestartet
es bricht das herz also das mit archie
und zerstachen es bliebe man seit jahren
grund wieso der so eine virtuelle und
leitet jetzt
das buch muss erst noch die familie
zieht also für mich
und meine familie ist das meiner familie
oder
feick ist ursprünglich aus der türkei
seit vier jahren ist er mit virginie
zusammen
zeigt sagt mir von anfang an sei klar
gewesen
wahrscheinlich gibt es nur im doppelpack
mit der moskau
st da muss man über seinen schatten
springen und das ist für mich
und das ist auch das schöne brauch
inzwischen ist feick in dieser spezielle
patchworkfamilie reingewachsen bei
bernie war es anders ihr zwillingsbruder
war seit jeher an ihrer seite
ca
zwei babys müssten sehr starke
nachricht
sofort
und den
rocksong müssen
jetzt richtig
der extrovertierte sie und ich die
introvertiert das kind und als
jugendlicher tisches bewegt sich das
sogar im mittelpunkt standen ist das
ganze jetzt eher lästig wunder dass er
immer so sagt aufmerksamkeit weckt
ich bin sehr versteckt ihre mami oder
gar
erst in der jugend ging wir sie ihren
eigenen weg
und
das haben wir gelegenheit gewohnt und
kann mich wie eine abgrenzung dass wir
mal
einen
sitz finden war es wichtig überhaupt was
wir für rollen ihn mir ich würde mir von
des mannes und damit die not und das
laminat sich mami bin da sie ja aber im
rahmen
ich frage mich wie viel platz bleibt wir
schon heute
klar ist samuel nimmt sich seinen raum
so auch jetzt er übt für seine
tanzgruppe
marvin entdeckt die welt samuel ist
polizei fan für ihn ist ordnung wichtig
zunehmend muss wer chemie zwischen den
beiden vermitteln
samuel hat seine eigene strategie um
konflikte zu verarbeiten
[Musik]
was man schon kommentieren
ein wichtiger teil von samuels leben
sind neben der schwester die eltern er
wohnt teilweise bei ihnen
bei der geburt ihrer kinder waren
rosemarie und emanuel bild überrascht
dies konnte down-syndrom zwillinge ein
äußerst seltenes phänomen
in der schweiz gibt es schätzungsweise
eine handvoll
prozent geschafft
ich habe dank jo zwilling oder das
arrangement rex grossman im schnitt
sowie sich
samuel stand wegen seiner
gesundheitlichen probleme von anfang an
im mittelpunkt der kinderarzt gab ihnen
einen rat
dass sie ja dass ich nicht nur immer das
haben wir uns einmal sammeln sondern
verschiedenartig obwohl kam die
spontanität immer wieder dass samuel was
macht jetzt will sony look schnell und
das hat ihr auch irgendwie die rolle
sie ist verantwortlich für das casting
tivoli spontanen erinnern um beiden
gerecht zu werden kämpften die beiden
behörden dass auch kinder mit
beeinträchtigungen in eine regelklasse
können mit erfolg samuel durfte in einen
regulären kindergarten im nachhinein
so viel frühjahr
vom kindergarten nachher vor allem
aber die hände zahl liegt um herrn k
die wende ein kontakt
und er wog kontakt zu behinderten
jahr gar alle die wir jetzt 230 sind und
down syndrom hat gesagt ich würde das
behinderte freund informiert worden ist
ja normal was falsch ist
die eltern wünschen sich dass samuel bei
virgin lebt wenn sie einmal nicht mehr
da sind
unterstützung wird er immer brauchen
obwohl er seinen arbeitsweg allein
bewältigen kann
vier tage pro woche arbeitet er in
münsterlingen in einer stiftung im
gartenbereich
heute stellt der wildbienenhotels her
angeleitet von seinem betreuer burger
pietschmann
das rolle von wildbienen chef setzt
studie wohnsituation nichts dass die
schwester wohnt ich finde es
grundsätzlich dass schwester wohnt
und und aber auch gern zum abi hat aber
genau dabei nicht samuel ist ein
erwachsener und das ist eigentlich
für deutliche wohnen gruppe h ein
eigenes die haie
wohl schon bedauerlich wohl jetzt wohl
auch begleitet den wohne aber woher
mehr abstand von der familie bislang
fielen
also weg stellt ich sehe da eine
sackgasse war es laut und thema
partnerwahl und zum thema wie ich da
wirklich war der frühling bringt damit
das haben wir in der neutralen umfeld
völlig neu tragen und fällt mir ein
freund mitbringen ohne dass irgendwelche
tisch oder auf die erfahrung und der
filmemacher
man muss klar immer die betätigung im
kontext der momox aber man muss trotzdem
so viel probieren auch versuche wie
möglich ist
selbstständig sein können
so so weit wie möglich
und so wenig wie möglich
in dieser stiftung findet auch ein teil
von samuels soziallebens statt
die
musik
und schöne frauen
[Musik]
ich treffe die zwillinge einen monat
später wieder
bis zur geburt des zweiten kindes dauert
es noch sechs wochen
[Musik]
ausgemacht dass man sagen muss sie ohne
reserve ist aktuell ein wahres ich muss
oft vor aber dass er
das
klappt gut und so stehen wir gerade wäre
die staaten
da ich wäre der sport sei
das bin ich da bin ich polizei
die kräfte fest die marvin diese today
will jetzt größere wird eine
selbständige das läuft alles richtig
aber ich bin sauber blieb das jagdliche
abhängig vor die jeder hat
wie ist das für die
das ist jetzt einfach so
wir sind in dieselbe weise genannt wir
sind jetzt
sowieso und für soziale gefühle ist mir
glücklich sind in der tat reichlich
unterstützung haben wir viel weniger der
einbuchung charakter wir haben
zur entlastung schon erschienen im zweig
samuel manchmal zum arbeit mit heute zum
christbaumverkauf
das knöpfle und grinst auf
noch zusätzlich hier wird
die
[Musik]
gegend wurde sind sie einfach jetzt bin
ich sogar sein vater
na ja und wie ist das wenn er
häufig nur cool und so und dann aber
wenn man das atmen
ich finde schon mit humor lustiger
werden
verschickt sogar
spaß aber nachher durch dana danke ja
bist du eigentlich die verantwortung
also auch lächerlich aber es ist
natürlich
schön denn ich sage jetzt meine fotos
dann akzeptierte damit
automatisch
ich kann schon gar nicht lange
jetzt diese kleine zu wissen gut können
nichts erklärt
peter kleiner abwinde
kleine aus der stadt lebe
was ist los
[Musik]
das noch gelegt
sie
schwebte geht's
nochmal gehöre
gelingt es ihn zu beruhigen
den rest klärt samuel wie üblich mit
seinen imaginären freunden
nein
aber lassen wir auch weglaufen na ja da
hat mich macht voll spaß
für alle
[Musik]
noch drei wochen bis zur geburt
früher morgen ist schon einiges los bei
virgin und ihrer familie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber
der beschluss kommt oder
solar- oder
gehabt
was definiert sie überhaupt wieder frei
und unabhängig
ich bin immer so lang so lange er sich
selber
also sagen dass frieden nicht über sie
ist also über sie sagen dann finde ich
aber
[Gelächter]
ich weiß dass ich
[Applaus]
das
[Musik]
besser
aber das ist gar nicht so einfach
und
hier in der tanzgruppe für menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen wäre eigentlich der
ideale ort um eine partnerin kennen zu
lernen aber eben alles frau nicht nach
samuels cousteau sie proben für ihren
auftritt in wenigen wochen
[Musik]
ich spüre ich
ich weiß nicht was in samuel vorgeht
genie sagte mir einmal selbst als
zwillingsschwester kenne sie dass das
beste dann die situation stehen lassen
oft sei es purer überforderungen mit
seinen emotionen die stimmung wechsel
meist von allein wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
papa
was ist der ruhigste man vom ganzen
die ruhe ist äußerst willkommen juni
steht kurz vor der geburt
ich hatte nicht so wie man wirklich zu
hause machen
und dann gut und
es ist ferien immer schaffe
[Musik]
hier
das ist schon nicht ungeduldig aber ich
war
nicht ganz neu
waren
lose oder seitdem zeigt
[Musik]
eines darf am abend nicht fehlen
nein
geduld der entscheides sammeln da ist
familie lage beeinflusst
wer wir
[Gelächter]
sind spontan vor
arbeitsgericht eine weniger privatsphäre
oder so zieht für uns oft geht es beiden
beiden um samuel besonders in der
letzten zeit er hat eine frau
kennengelernt sie ist 60 jahre alt ohne
beeinträchtigung das
thema was machst du hier und alles und
er hat einfach sie bedürfen ist dass das
haben wir alle dann 0 und und das ist
dann schon die zweifache
knifflig komisch so wirfst du mont und
glücklich dass ich wirklich liebe
und weil man ja alle dem werkstor
ausgeschaltetem samuel und dominik oder
galaxy will halt davos gegenüber den
sich von so einer verschlossenheit oder
nicht mir jetzt tun haben mit uns über
einen start mit wie viel fürs ohr
brauchte und wie viel freiraum und wo
gott sind die bmw
schwierige
frage bereitet
partnerschaftliche auch
für die also ich für mich selbst
entscheiden ist es schon schwierig und
dennoch die ganze frage denn dafür
opfert anders die
gleichzeitig mit der ema mit deiner
frage wir mit dem freiheit selber zu
entscheiden sagt scheide wie viel vom
stapel mit die ganzen konsequenzen
wurden nach hinzu
ja
genau oder das sagt er
dass ich und das ist ein schwieriges
thema sicherlich sharks voraus ich weiß
nicht was ich
weiß ist sehr einfach
nicht in ordnung aber jetzt 1 700
kontakten eine gute haben und das ist
einfacher freundschaft und das ist gut
so
nach zwei monaten treffe ich sie wieder
inzwischen auf der welt der kleine
mai/juni
erzählt mir die zeit seit der geburt sei
schwierig gewesen sie kämpfte mit dem
babyblues samuel wohnte phasenweise
ausschließlich bei den eltern und sie
hat ihre stelle gekündigt die beziehung
zwischen ihr und feig bleibe immer noch
auf der strecke
persönlichkeit
und da etwas machen ja wie zu seiner
rede versucht ihn zu schlagen
[Musik]
das einzig aber die idee war auch das
jetzt wieder raus der familie gab sich
zu entspannen das thema ja natürlich das
hier immer wieder diskussionen kommt
letztlich hat der chef rolle gefunden
es war er fährt besser wenn das betreute
wohnen wir wollen aber
dass ich glaube das spiel jede
wohnsituation was geht da vor um
nachteil und
das dafür dass mir einfach immer wieder
sagt zimmer mit überprüfen stehen
momentan stimmt für
beziehungen sind nichts statisches immer
wieder überprüfen wohl eine gute lösung
heute bei helden und heldinnen 21 von in
szene ist der große auftritt von samuels
tanzgruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es sind weg
samuel und wir sind glücklich nicht nur
wegen des auftritts
und zwar was gefunden
wo
platz für alle ist
die vollständige mitbringt das mikro
wohnzimmer küche und esszimmer mit
eigenem eingang für ihn
wenn sie mit mahlzeiten der freud und
leid gab zu ein kunde oder super und zu
mal dass ein abkommen mit
dieser logik gemacht oder
bis großinvestition
lage uns nicht machen
[Gelächter]
immer noch nicht die strang und
schwester oder wohin mit recht wiese
oder
erst hatte man immer mit nichts
richtig machen
die vorzeichen stehen gut den
gemeinsamen weg glücklich fortzusetzen
mit einer gesunden mischung aus nähe und
distanz um sich frei zu entwickeln jede
und jeder auf seine weise
[Musik]
aha